ừ ừ
anh
Alo Alo
Alo ạ
anh
alo alo alo
Anh ở đã tự nhiên tiền bé nghỉ Alo ở đây
này ok
à à
anh alo
Xin chào các bạn Hôm nay chắc là ăn sớm
tí vì hôm nay được cả có khá nhiều sự
chia sẻ cũng như là
khi trả lời các câu hỏi của trước mùa
trước nhưng mình quên không trả lời anh
là run run có hỏi sang tận buổi hôm nay
hôm nay được ra cũng chia sẻ nhiều phép
hôm nay mình sẽ định chia sẻ
hai cái một cái là
khi
cài là cách viết khi hát rồi mà trong
kết hợp của mình hiện tại mình không nói
nó đang rất là đẹp rất ngầu gì gì đó cho
tôi đúng ở mình cảm thấy nó rất là sự
thật Nhưng mà mình mình mình cảm thấy
kiểu không nên giữ cho riêng mình mà bản
chất là mình cũng đi có ở trên mạng về
thôi nên mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn để mà
làm rất nhiều các bạn có thể để làm cái
tương tự thì
Ừ thì cũng không không nên lắm mà nên
làm nên học cách để mà làm những cái có
thể đẹp hơn tiện hơn nó trong phù hợp
với các bạn hơn tiếng nhỏ để mình di sát
và mình lại quên chắc mình phải nuốt lại
đi lại làm mua thấy hay thì mình nhắn
cho
anh chị cho nóc nhà là mua cái treo mic
Ừ chứ cứ ngồi gì ý sát vào cái mic kiểu
này chắc cả chồng trong đau lưng á ừ ừ
à à
ở
trên ảnh b-code base64
hình như là được Đấy nó gửi bạn chất vào
nó
Ừ nó kiểu ở cái clip mi nào dùng móc
down mình dùng Mà thẻ img vẫn được mà
à à
em alo tiếng to hơn rồi đó ạ
Ừ thôi bé đầu tiên mình chia sẻ phải cá
nhé
ở đầu tiên thì ở
em làm dạy học như thế này chắc anh kiên
trì dữ dội lắm
Mình nghĩ là mỗi ngày nghề thì nó vẫn là
có cái kiểu Có cái khó khăn riêng của nó
thì Nhưng mà khi dạy này thì công nhận
là mình cảm thấy á
vừa dạy vừa phải dỗ có nếu mày giờ đỡ
hơn so với kiểu tiểu học mẫu giáo gì đó
nếu mà nó cũng sẽ có bất tiện hơn riêng
một vài cái thôi mình đi dậy hồi mình đi
dạy à cho sinh viên thì ta mình khó chịu
việc là sinh viên của trường cũ của mình
thì nó là kiểu nó kiểu dạng là
nhờ bạn nghĩa đóng tiền đến đấy là Anh
là qua được môn là có được cái bằng ấy
ngồi trường mình kiểu nó không nổi và
nói chung và kiểu
thì kệ tuyển đầu vào nó kiểu không giống
như đại học chính quy khá là dễ vào
thành ra toàn những cái ông mà kiểu
Trượt đại học những cái ông mà cậu không
vào được đâu vào chả hạn cũng có một vài
thành phần như thế anh ra kiểu đi dạy
cho mấy người khá là mệt Lúc đầu họ có
có muốn học đâu họ cũng xác định có theo
ngày này đâu đó ngoại thành ra là kiểu
ăn giỗ khá nhiều dạy hay ít mà dỗ nhiều
hơn
khi mình vẫn còn bé có khi ông phải xem
lại xem các bạn khác thì thấy mi có có
đủ to chưa
ông chưa Thế này là quá to gì để
đúng kiểu gì xanh hết mất rồi đấy
mình nói bé chắc thế ừ ừ
trò chuyện thì nói chung là cái việc
kiên kiên nhẫn của mình hồi đấy cũng khá
phải kiên nhẫn cái việc đấy cũng khá làm
là khi mà kiểu Khi mà
mình nhiều lúc mà mình muốn dậy rất
nhiều cái Giả sử nhiều cái mình dậy
chuyên sâu ở ở
trên này như thế này phải chưa lớp mình
khó được dạy lắm Bởi vì à dạy cơ bản bọn
nó còn phải mất khá nhiều Buổi rồi mà
nghe chưa Làm bài tập đấy Em hãy ra kiểu
không để dậy những cái chuyên sâu được
em chỉ dạy được nhận được cơ bản thôi
Được ra làm mình cảm thấy cũng dễ bị
được trí kiểu kiến thức của mình bị lãng
phí
ừ ừ
khi cây câu của bạn này Hôm nay mình
cũng sẽ giải đáp này đó là sẽ dùng những
cái hàm ghét ở đây mình có thứ Thử như
thế nào
cách truyền tham số vào hàm để in ra ở
tí mình sẽ dạy các bạn về vụ là có thể ở
dùng nhiều hàm
từ lần trước mọi khi mình chị dùng đúng
bật hàm Thôi bây giờ mình sẽ thử dùng
nhiều hàm thôi truyền cấp hàm số và các
bạn sẽ lấy hình dung nó như thế nào
Ờ annimation cũng làm bằng da skip hả
Anh thì cho cái bản chất ra Swift đó nó
là làm cho
Ừ nó làm cho thay đổi HTML CS CS mấy làm
animation làm hiệu ứng cầu chuyển động
vào thứ thứ nhưng mà để cho thằng ngày
nó nhảy sang chữ to hơn hai thằng này
làm cho từ trái sang phải gánh mạ vàng
chất thì nó là
ra Swift nó sẽ can thiệp vào CS của nó
để đẩy cho nó ra họ để nói hiển thị ra
Vân nó không ạ Thế nên là animation làm
hiệu ứng thì đúng là làm ra Suite II
đi siêu âm vẫn đang trong mùa thi cử nhỉ
em tính
có lần cuối mình thi kể trường liên
thông thì chở ra rồi Khá là dễ học đến
thôi công nhận là dễ mà Thiệu dễ được
mang phao đi em ạ
Cái này không không không giấu diếm gì
cả nhưng mà mình đi vẫn tự làm mình như
con đỉa ngồi trước làm đặc biệt là làm
mấy cái câu trách nhiệm mình từ nó đó là
Ờ mình sẽ luôn nhìn vào đáp án này đoàn
câu hỏi mình không không cần nhìn câu
hỏi luôn
Làm trắc nghiệm kiểu như thế nó mới gần
nhân phẩm nó mới hay nếu sẽ gì cả nhìn
vào đa bàn thôi Em đoán xem câu hỏi nó
là gì
vì thế mà tội là nào tối hôm qua bây giờ
hả chống trượt
ở những hàng phổ biến của aj và chuỗi
Chắc là buổi sau buổi sau là chó là buổi
sau sẽ là mỗi cuối của Switch vừa hôm
nay là Bộ hôm nay sẽ rất là dài thời ra
buổi hôm nay rất là dài mình sẽ dạy toàn
toàn bộ về virus của Swift các thứ áp
dụng kiến thức công trước gạch Nói chung
là từ bỏ hôm trước rồi các bạn đã sẽ
phải khá là thấy mức độ khó tăng dần rồi
bởi vì nó liên quan đến viên lập trình
thiếu cầu kiến thức mới buổi hôm nay áp
dụng kiến thức đấy luôn Sau đó gì bởi
Hôm sau nữa lại không Ôn tập lại gần như
là không có ôn lại các bạn sẽ chỉ có làm
bài tập để mà tự ôn thôi Ừ đúng ạ Các
bạn nếu mà làm bài tập xong mà vẫn quê
mình chắc là các bạn sẽ phải tự nghĩ đến
bài tập về làm tự nghĩ trên đề là
em chưa gần như là không không thể buổi
hôm nay thì ôn tập bấm trước tập đi học
trên trường được
lễ hội các bạn có video quay lại các từ
có chứ
khi sex
Ừ cái vụ mình đề cập ở đây vệ sai chính
tả ra clip này như thế mình sẽ nói qua
việc khi mà kiểu ra skip các bạn kiểu nộ
của Pháp có từ từ thứ thì nó sẽ không
chạy ngoài việc nó không chạy thì nó sẽ
như thế nào sẽ lỗi như là nhìn chị xem
lỗi như nào và nó có gửi ảnh hưởng như
thế nào
từ hôm nay nhiều ông muốn xui à
Ừ không sao mấy ông xem lại tôi tôi thấy
được à nó không xem lại nhiều mà mày
không lượng người xem ví dụ giả thứ bây
giờ xem có đúng mấy trăm thôi nha em ơi
à mà khi mà xem video thấy giờ lên hơn
nhìn anh một lần ấy ông kia xem đi xem
lại hay là hay là gấu có mấy ông hiểu
không xem trực tiếp được
Cho tôi xem lại video tôi Tôi cảm thấy
cũng phải
cũng phải tua nhanh lên Đấy mình quen
nhiều U nói chậm rồi Lên cầu xem video
lại mấy cái tô nhanh
là thứ da cơ thể dễ học miễn là có xem
kiểu live chat như này các bạn dễ hình
dung hơn mà nó ngon ạ
khi sex
a Tiếp theo là cái câu này thì ra hôm
trước đang định bảo là
ở
các tiệm vẫn bé
Em không hiểu Mọi khi mình vẫn đang nói
như thế này nhỉ
Em có biết có thay đổi gì không alo
anh alo
anh alo alo alo
Em không biết được không biết bé hay như
nào
em alo tiếng toàn chưa ạ alo alo
em vừa rồi mình mình không chỉnh gì cả
Không biết được nó ảnh hưởng gì không ạ
anh alo Naruto hơn chưa
à à Lại
Ừ ok ờ
a Tiếp theo là cái vụ ngoan đúng không
trùng hôm trước là tôi định cho câu này
thành câu sao rồi
Ừ ừ đúng rồi tôi tôi
tôi đeo tai nghe mà tai nghe tôi để mà
biết được xem mình nói toi bé thì có vẻ
Tôi vừa rút ra cắm lại có vẻ thế To hơn
nữa Chắc là bây giờ nói to rồi
ờ ờ cái vụ Lan đâm Không chồng thì hôm
trước định cho có sao cuối cùng vì quên
mất thì à
từ hôm nay nữa không có thời gian giải
đáp Hôm nay tôi sẽ cho nó lành câu sao
dễ cho nó ra để mà không nào dạy và hôm
sau nữa tôi sẽ chữa bài không sao buổi
cuối sẽ chữa hết
ờ ờ
cái câu bao giờ học xong
Ừ cái cái có mày thật ra thì không biết
là không chớp mình chả được nghỉ
cách cài 3G học xong của của bạn này nó
rất rộng
Vì vậy các bạn thì sẽ chẳng giờ học xong
cả theo kiểu là đến bây giờ bản thân
mình theo ngành lập trình này đến bây
giờ mình vẫn phải học Mình vẫn phải học
nhá thì học rất nhiều thứ và còn rất
nhiều thứ cảm thấy kiểu chẳng hề chẳng
hiểu gì cả chẳng biết gì cả
Ừ nhưng mà nhưng mà kiểu mình cảm thấy
là
khi mình đã đến nó cái ngưỡng mà kiểu
nói chung là cũng hơn được khá nhiều
ở nhà phải dùng từ hơn được khá nhiều ở
vịt kiểu
ạ bây bây giờ cậu
Ừ cái
khi sex
anh nghe cái trang CV của mình kiểu được
khánh khá nhiều kiểu nhà Tuyển dụng kiểu
nhắn tin tôi cảm thấy rồi cũng tự hào
phết khi mà kiểu họ săn đón mình các thứ
thứ họ đã ngộ mình các thử thứ thì lúc
đấy mới cảm thấy là kiểu mình à
khi mình học và được xứng đáng đêm đền
đáp các thứ thứ
Ừ cái cái việc đấy nó khác với nhiều
ngành chiều Các bạn có thể 3 4 năm kinh
nghiệm ở những hình khác thì nó không
bao giờ săn đuổi bằng cái ngày này mình
đang cảm thấy thế
ở các ngành khác thì có bạn sẽ phải đi
kèm với cả bằng cấp rồi Vân Vân mối quan
hệ giữa xử lý nữa
em phải có tặng em tên tuổi luôn Vân nữa
còn không cho ngành này các bạn sẽ cần
đến tuổi gì cả các bạn chỉ cần cộng với
cv có cậu có năng lực thật sự họ sẽ cầu
đãi ngộ của bạn do tốt Thế nên là mình
cảm thấy à Nó vẫn xứng đáng
A và còn cái ý bao giờ học xong của bạn
đấy nếu mà theo
Ừ nếu mà theo kiểu
từ
khóa học này của mình gì Ừ thì chắc à
bây bây giờ là học ra Swift xong này
có thể tuần này chắc là xong ra Swift
này sau đó đi học p p p thì mình sẽ cũng
không nhắc lại bên lập trình như là cũng
sẽ khá là nhanh để mở từ P sang kết hợp
với máy kia Word để mà
anh hình dung về toàn bộ các tính năng
kiểu đầy đủ tính năng xem thêm sửa xóa
xông vào đăng nhập
đăng nhập đăng ký ạ đó sau đó thì à
mình mình sẽ ghét toàn bộ tất cả từ đợi
các cài đấy lại để mà làm ra được một
cái trang web cơ bản
ở một trang web lúc đầu trang web 3tin
tức sau đó đã làm trang web bán hàng
Ừ Thì
có mấy cái đấy Mỗi buổi mình sẽ lại để
mô từng tính năng 1 của mình cái trang
web ấy thì chắc là tầm mà
anh có thể hai tháng nữa hai tháng hai
đang rưỡi nữa là sẽ dậy sóng hết
trong thời gian đấy các bạn cũng lúc lúc
mà bắt đầu làm lúc bắt đầu làm mấy cái
trang web tin tức tất cả
bán hàng đấy thì các bạn cũng sẽ được
chia nhóm để mà ghép nhóm với nhau để mà
làm đề tài luôn thì à
Vì sao bỏ đi chắc là chó các bạn thời
gian để mà các bạn à hoàn thiện cái đồ
An đấy để mà
Anh ở sau đó tầm một tháng có thể thế
ai chả thế để mà các bạn
các bạn bảo vệ không ạ
em à nhưng mà trăm về rồi năm tháng đấy
mình cũng sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn cách bảo
vệ như nào cách làm tài liệu như thế nào
cần ngoan vân nóng ạ Vì mà nói chung mà
các bạn sẽ hiểu qua về cái
tiến trình là một cái dự án một cái sản
phẩm công nghệ thông tin
Ừ từ đầu đến cuối từ việc làm tài liệu
thuyết trình làm Powerpoint
và sau đó thì
làm ra cái sản phẩm Phân tích các thứ
thứ xe tải thì nó sẽ là như thế nào
và đương nhiên là
thì mình sẽ còn cả việc chữa cho các bạn
nữa
anh có chắc là những buổi những buổi để
nói chung nhà 1 tháng đấy sẽ không hiểu
mình mất tích mà là sẽ chữa bài cho các
bạn cũng như hỗ trợ các bạn gì đấy hỗ
trợ cho anh chị hội chợ online nội dung
mới có thừa thứ thôi chứ không không
kiểu trực tiếp được không ạ
ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ thì tranh thủ cho các bạn ạ Có
ông vừa nãy hỏi về cái vụ mà chữa bài
hôm trước
em là cây bài mã màu không ạ
anh được tí nhớ nhỏ nhắc mình sửa chữa
cho bài các bạn phục đây
Ừ mình mới Xem lại video này buồn cười
chết mình cho bạn xem nữa Biết rồi quết
rồi
if you Guess which fastest way to
break the Style
of What we got it during video
Thành Mobile
Shell
gadus amedred
you sweat Fitness for the welfare of
meat grinder
Winner for the
welfare of
What we have all of which one you love
days ago since when i
anh ạ
các bạn Các bạn xem mấy giờ rồi thực
thực tế Nó là kiểu đi
em làm lập làm được trình mình như thế
giờ người dùng sẽ Kiều dùng gái rượu của
vần ông ạ Mà kẹo mình mình cho rất nhiều
cái đầu để mà nhập vào nhưng mà nó chỉ
nhập vào đúng cái chẳng hạn thế
Ừ thì đấy đấy buổi hôm nay mình sẽ học
cái đét là để kiểm tra việc của người
dùng nhập vào như thế nào thông báo cho
người dùng như thế nào là chuyện người
dùng hiểu không ạ
ở
đâu rõ ràng hướng dẫn các từ có chứa
trong nó hẹ rõ ràng như kiểu hiển nhiên
như thế ở nhau người dùng vẫn phải nhập
sai người dùng cố tình như thế hỏi người
dùng
hiểu chưa Dùng máy tính bao giờ nhăn
không hiểu Nó là cái gì
Ờ Ờ
mình trả lời nói câu này Ờ học file thì
nên chọn phương Quốc nào nó tương tự
giống như là kiểu mình sẽ từng nói qua
việc học cũng giống cho học ngôn ngữ lập
trình Vậy thì bạn sẽ thì ở các bạn đương
nhiên là vẫn nên tìm những cái mà kéo
lên phổ biến phổ biến một phần nào để mà
sẽ đi làm vệ sinh việc vân vân và cũng
như cộng đồng Hỗ trợ nó rất là ôi
xã hội hỗ trợ ở đây hỗ trợ việc mà
Ngôn ngữ này nó còn phát triển lâu dài
chứ không phải nó chuẩn bị sắp thành
ngôn ngữ đã chết cũng như là
các bạn tra lỗi nó nó xảy ra tra tài
liệu nó có ra rất nhiều mà đôi khi là
các bạn điển hình gần đây mình làm để vụ
là Google api về mà nhận nhận diện giọng
nói được ạ thì cái Mun Ngôn ngữ này nó
có hỗ trợ tài liệu để mà đọc 20 các thứ
thứ đấy thì mai mai mà mình mình đọc
thấy có vải có vài ngôn ngữ có đúng ngôn
ngữ của mình
Giả sử một mấy cái thằng này mà không có
ngôn ngữ của mình thì chắc là mình thì
sàng đầu tiên tiên phong là vụ đấy xác
chết không ạ chị sẽ rất là mệt
em vừa cách tra phương Quốc Ở đang đang
rượu đang đứng đầu thì các bạn Phim Quốc
tốt ngày hay cái gì đó vương quốc 20 21
2022 này
thì các bạn chàng này nó sẽ ra hải ngoại
gà qué tự tạo bằng việc kéo tha
AE theo kiểu lướt web so web tạo bằng
cốt thì cần nó chạy nhanh hơn
cho nó luôn là web chạy bằng Cốt nó sẽ
chạy nhanh hơn thế là cái câu web chạy
bằng chạy bằng cốc thì nó hơi sai vì vừa
cơ bản cả hai nó để tạo bởi cốt chẳng
qua là à Cả hai đều chạy bằng cốt chẳng
qua là cái cái việc kéo thả thì nó sẽ tự
sinh ra cốt còn việc tạo bởi cốt thì nó
tạo bởi cốt Thuần dưỡng mình tự gõ đúng
không Thì cái việc tự sinh ra cốc thì nó
nó có bài toán là nó sẽ sinh ra thự kiểu
là
đôi khi không tối ưu thứ nhất là nó
không có tất cả trường hợp
đã có rất nhiều trường hợp mà kiểu mình
không muốn nó lại có mặt thừa dữ liệu a
và và kiểu nó không Tuy chỉnh nó cho là
không tùy chuyển và không tối ưu ái nó
luôn là 2 yếu tố đấy thành cho thành ra
được web tạo bởi kéo thả thì nó nhanh
nhưng mà nó rẻ web tạo bởi cốt thì nó
kiểu tắt hệ thống nhà làm cái trang bằng
gỗ vest giá 1 triệu có 3 triệu tầm tầm
tầm đấy thôi còn web mà tạo bởi cốt thì
giá nó luôn là 10 20 triệu đấy Đấy là ít
nhé Vậy có nhiều ở trang web bây giờ
Điền hình các phần mềm được 100 triệu có
tiền tỉ nó có
anh nghe Kiều Hoa
thì các bạn so sánh Thế thì nó là bởi vì
thời gian để mà làm cái đấy nó khác nữa
tạo bởi web tạo bởi kéo thả thì có thể
một người không cần biết ngôn ngữ lớp
chính chỉ cần biết qua Dùng cái đấy
trong vòng một tuần người ta vừa học vừa
làm đã làm xong một cái trang web đầy đủ
tính năng rồi còn để mà
tư vấn đề mà học từ đầu đến cuối để mà
làm 5 cái trang web làm tất cả tính năng
bằng cái cái trang web đó là kia chưa
chán các bạn mất phải 34 tháng này ít
ở đấy chưa nói mình đón tối ưu
khi nó mới chỉ ở chỗ nào mới biết cốc
thôi còn tối với ở đây là tối ưu về việc
tối ưu cho nó chạy nhanh này kết hợp với
việc là
chỉ cốt sao cho để mã về xã hội khách
hàng mà một thêm tính năng mới muốn thay
đổi cái gì đó thì dễ thay đổi chẳng hạn
thì cái đấy các bạn học phải hai ba năm
ấy lúc đấy chưa Sẵn cái kinh nghiệm với
nó sẽ
sẽ đòi hỏi tiền không ạ Các bạn nghe về
vụ nhát búa 1.000 đô 50.000 đô rồi rồi
chưa
the Law in 150 cũ
anh nghe có mùi giống nhờ mấy cái ông
lớn đi lại
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ đến giờ học
rồi đầu tiên thì hôm trước có mấy ông
đang cái mê cày cốt freegate mày cái mã
túi rách của mấy ông Thực ra tôi xin
phép chia sẻ mấy ông thực ra không để ý
việc là cái trang này có thể đăng nhập
Ở trang này có gì em nhỉ
ạ Và nếu không có thể đăng nhập xong thì
bị ông có xếp li cách này sau đó với mấy
ông chia sẻ mấy cái link đấy bạn thân
tôi cũng cũng từng đăng nhật để mà lưu
lại mấy cái
mấy cái dưới của riêng tôi
Ừ thôi để tôi làm cái rách cả tài địa
chỉ họ tên thế họ tên đầy đủ à
ở các giàu ai về tôi đi có mà ở đây mấy
ông Chaly Cách tiếng Việt là dao như có
mùi gõ thì vậy
ở đây này ừ ừ
a a a
có thể rút ra trường hợp A Hồi đấy rồi
nhớ có trường hợp ở đây Hình chưa có một
cái trường hợp ở đấy đợi cha ấy tự nhiên
không không có chữ thế thôi tự nhiên tôi
cậu một bắt được cái lỗi đấy tôi phải
muốn sửa lại cái chữ tự nhiên phải thêm
chữ ế
cười vậy
anh qua đây Tôi làm gái cả về
link Facebook hay các thứ thứ cái đấy
cho về sau tuổi chia sẻ thêm người ôm
sao vậy mày không hình dung được cách nó
thể làm những gì nhưng đây Nói chung vào
mấy ông làm này xong rồi mày không có
thể chia sẻ này
ạ bấm bấm vào để đào tạo đến trưa xe thì
ổn hơn nữa có gửi cái đoạn cốt kia vừa
chia sẻ kia là chia sẻ luôn cả những cái
trường hợp mà Mấy ông đã test người ông
đã kiểu ghi
a ghi các trường hợp ra để tôi nhìn qua
nhưng có là việc tôi sẽ đánh giá luôn
này việc là mấy ông kỹ các trường hợp để
mà test như thế nào chứ không phải về
mỗi cốt không ạ
ở mỗi cốc thì tôi nhập vào đúng thì có
thể nó vẫn chạy đấy nhưng mà nhập sai mà
nó vẫn báo đúng thì là vấn đề ngay đúng
không ạ
Ừ cái câu này mình xin phép ta
em trả lời sau trở giao động
Ừ cái này dùng quyết được cái này dùng
rách được ta làm sao biết email đồ có
tồn tại không hôm trước và hôm trước có
bạn hỏi câu này Hôm trước mình mới chỉ
làm verde để kiểm tra Email nhập hợp lệ
còn việc là nó giống như kiểu tên nó hợp
lễ Ê chúng mày còn việc Tên nó có đúng
là tên người không chẳng hạn thì phải
hỏi họ đúng không thấy dùng cái gì đó
chứng minh họ là thưởng tuổi hợp lệ tuổi
thật thằng Đản đúng không ạ thì cái
email là anh thế cách để kiểm tra Email
của tôi tại không mình chỉ an toàn họ
lại họ bằng cách gửi mail cho họ đấy là
một cách
Anh
thường là thường là làm như thế thôi ta
Nó có bị nhược điểm một tí đó là việc
gửi mail cho họ đôi khi sẽ rơi vào ở thư
mục giác của họ cũng như là gửi mail
người ta cũng tốn phí đó nhá gửi mail
hay gửi tin nhắn qua số điện thoại nó
tốn phí nên thành ra là
Ừ anh nên thành ra là kiểu nó cũng hơi
bị nhược điểm tí nữa là có nhiều cách đó
là vẫn chí là ông có thể kiểm tra quay
qua bên thứ ba trước mình Thứ ba là một
vài bên những cái bên mà nó thường ấy
cung cấp máy cần mau ra đấy đấy Nếu
không có người kiểm tra qua chính này
cái mấy cái Trang đấy trước và kiểm tra
xem mail này có được đánh đăng ký Bởi
bởi mấy cái trang này không nghe Chứng
tỏ là em yêu này được đăng ký rồi một
cái trang music giống kẹo cái mail
ten-minute Milk
có mail cỡ này nghĩa là có những cái
mail mà cả các bạn muốn năm ký một cái
gì đỏ nhanh ở các bạn chỉ muốn hiểu nó
gửi về cho các bạn một cái gì đó
một cái đoạn Mã gì đó rồi Các bạn đăng
ký mua gì bỏ ngang và các bạn sẽ chẳng
mơ vào lại thời trang này nữa thường vào
đấy để tải một cái gì đó đôi khi các bạn
không ở spam quảng cáo các bạn về sau
không muốn lưu lại nếu các bạn về sau
thì đây Có những cái trang kiểu nó sẽ
tạo cho các bạn một cái mail kiểu như
thế này và hoàn toàn các bạn sẽ nhận
được tin cậy Miu nào đó gửi vào cho các
bạn qua đây Đấy Và mail này sẽ chỉ tồn
tại trong vòng 10 phút mười phút sau
được cái mail này sẽ bị xóa mây ở phù
hợp cho việc là kiểu các bạn đi đăng ký
ở để lấy kiểu kiểu như thế
Ừ đấy thi thì chính cái những cái kiểu
như này gọi là Nêu giác này trước cửa là
nó sẽ kiểu nó
để nhận biết được nó lại phải kiểm tra
xem chính cái b thứ ba trên chính những
cái trang này xem mail có đăng ký ở trên
đấy không được như thế
Ừ
vợ kiến thức mới giống mình thì
à mình làm được trình mai biết mấy cái
vụ này
thì các bạn phạm luật trình xong các bạn
sẽ biết được có rất nhiều cái kiến thức
mới theo kiểu là
cứ nail giả cảm giác như vừa rồi từ việc
là kiểu tại rất nhiều ông Làm lập trình
tạo ra rất nhiều cái nó khó hiểu lắm
nhưng mà nó tiện nhưng mà nó khó hiểu
lắm kéo các bạn sẽ không đồng ý Ôi có
người làm cái này rồi à cái rồi Thế các
bạn đôi khi và thỉnh thoảng phải tra xem
người việc có thằng nào làm đấy chưa khi
mà hồi học lập trình ở tôi bộ Tôi bị như
thế đấy Đó là luôn luôn tra xem là có
nào đã làm cái này chưa phải chuyện ra
là có rất nhiều ông đã từng nghĩ về việc
đấy và làm cái đấy rồi đấy nó giống như
kiểu phát minh vĩ đại vậy thế
Đó
là những cái này cái quan trọng ở những
cái này thì chị Bọn tôi biết thôi Bọn
tôi ít khi mà công khai cho cho tất cả
mọi người cùng biết Liên là Nhưng mà
thỉnh thoảng có một vài không công khai
cái đấy xã chẳng hạn đăng lên Tik Tok
không ạ whey bao nhiêu ông vào đâu được
Cảm thấy có được khai sáng thứ nhưng thử
ta với người dân trong nghề như vợ tôi
thì nó là điều quá hình những kiểu biết
từ lâu lắm rồi
nhanh thế
Ừ thế là tôi đang nghĩa là tôi chia sẻ
cho mấy ông thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ chia sẻ
mấy cái kiểu có thể như thế nhưng đâu
Béo mới thích không ạ
ai nói học và Tik Tok không ạ mái tóc
đôi khi những cái bịp đấy Chẳng qua gặp
mấy ông gần hết trong nó vôi thưa mấy
ông ông đang ở trên Tik Tok thì cũng
kiểu để câu được xem chủ yếu chứ
thứ kiến thức có khi chưa chắc là chuẩn
à à
Ừ
Ok Thôi giải dám qua em nói chung đến 3
hôm nay thì bài hôm nay nó sẽ sinh ra
một vấn đề như thế này ờ bài hôm nay ở
sinh năm gần đây như thế này Tại sao tự
nhiên hôm nay mình sẽ học đấy cái khái
niệm là validate form thì đầu tiên là
như vừa nãy mình có đề cập dịch vụ là
kiểm tra cho người dùng nhập đúng đúng
không ạ Tức là xa thì tại sao lại phải
kiểm tra người dùng nhập đúng
thì mình sẽ ra hỏi lại câu đấy ông ạ
ở đó đó là giờ sửa D1 Phong đăng ký hả
đúng không ạ Phong đăng ký của người
dùng và người dùng nhập bên ta tinh cũng
được chấp nhận thì ra là không nên như
thế đúng không ạ Đấy do mình sẽ kiểm tra
nào ạ nhưng mà tự nhiên ở đây lại có bài
toán nữa tự nhiên tại sao lại kiểm tra
bằng Switch đúng không ạ Hôm trước đã
từng của bạn hỏi là em kiểm tra bằng
ngôn ngữ ở bên bác em và ngôn ngữ xử lý
ở server được không ạ
Ừ cái cái này khái niệm này nó hơi bị
nó hơi bị lạ với các bạn thì các bạn còn
chưa biết bác em là gì thì mình cho xin
phép cho các bạn xem cả
vides Tom nhạc
Em không biết có ảnh này không Để mình à
Chỗ bạn dễ hình dung ra hết phần em đi ừ
em có cái ảnh sơ đồ để mà các bạn dễ
hình dung
Ừ cái này cũng tương tự cái này được này
cho bạn xem ảnh này được đấy
Ừ cái này trông có vẻ nhiều chữ hơn nhỉ
Không thích kiểu nhiều chữ quá ngay Mình
mình không thích nhiều chữ đâu Mình nghĩ
thích cái gì đó cho một cái ý chữ rồi
Ừ cái này trông kiểu đúng kiểu Yeah được
tôi sẽ thích kiểu Yeah I
10 cái này lại thiếu thiếu thông tin mất
rồi
ừ thôi lấy tạm cái này nhé Cái này sẽ là
sao nghĩa là gì
ờ ờ ờ
ý nghĩa là đầu tiên thì mình sẽ xử lý
virus ở phía client tức là phía phía
người dùng rất là cụ thể là chân chính
máy của người dùng mình sẽ ngồi kiểm tra
bằng ra sweep trước là người dùng nhập
Đúng là nhập sai ra quyết về sẽ chạy lên
chín cái trình duyệt của người dùng là
chương trình máy người dùng ngoạn
sau đó thì nhưng mà kiểm tra thì vẫn chỉ
kiểm tra ở một mức tương đối được tương
đối tại sao mình lại dùng từ tương đối
bởi vì a giống như là như vừa rồi có đề
cập là giả sử là mình chỉ kiểm tra được
là người dùng nhập email có đúng cú pháp
hay không chứ mình không kiểm tra được
là được email đấy có có tồn tại hay
không mình không kiểm tra rồi đấy ở trên
máy này dùng được mà mình sẽ mình sẽ bị
đẩy về trên server để mình kiểm tra
trong server trong server của mình
nhờ server mình sẽ thông báo lại cái
email đấy có thể gửi mail cho chính nó
xong rồi server xác nhận sau đó đi trả
về cho khách hàng là email để hợp lệ rồi
ạ thì server sẽ làm cái vụ kiểm tra Lặng
Bước cuối
mà tại sao lại phải gọi dùng thực kiểm
tra bất cuối bởi vì ạ thực tế ạ là người
dùng có thể tắt được de Suite ở trên
chính máy của họ là sửa như thế này các
bạn ấn vào
và một trang web bất kỳ này các bạn ấn
vào đây này Ở no size setting này ấn vào
ra Swift này mặc định nó đang ở lao
nhưng các bạn thì ấn Vlog như thế này mà
các bạn tải lại trang là là cái Trang
đấy sẽ không bơ được chạy ra súp nữa thi
thì sẽ không dùng Speed để mà virus được
dữ liệu
Vì thế nên là thế thì nên là kiểu gì
server cũng sẽ phải kiểm tra bước cuối
nếu mà trong trường hợp mà da súp ít bị
tắt hay là thậm chí là người dùng có thể
ghi đè ra Switch của các bạn vì như lần
trước mình có đề cập và các bạn ở Mỹ
Spec này cần con show này xong rồi các
bạn trình một cái gì đó
a gỗ kouji a xít vào trong ngày là đồng
nghĩa là ra Switch cũ nó sẽ bị ghi đè
lên theo kiểu là ghi đề hàm hay các thứ
thì thì thì nó sẽ nó sẽ kiểu bọ Nói
chung là bỏ qua họ rất nhiều cách để mà
lách bởi vì trên máy người dùng mà nên
thành người dùng làm cái gì chẳng được
đóng ạ nên thành ra là server võ vạch
kiểm tra quá cô ấy
Ừ thì có bạn sẽ thắc mắc ở đây cái Tại
sao làm server kiểu dáng phải kiểm tra
Tại sao em lại không em không để sâu với
kiểm tra thôi em bỏ qua ở trên máy người
dùng bởi vì ở đây bài toán đấy Giả sử là
giả sử như thằng Facebook chẳng hạn
Facebook nó có
bây giờ hiện tại truy cập lượng truy cập
đồng thời đang có đang phải trăm triệu
trăm triệu lấy ít người đang cùng dùng
cùng một lúc Đông ạ Nếu mà cứ đẩy lên
server rồi server mới kiểm tra thì quá
tải cho server đó ngoại hay bị như thế
chính máy của người dùng sẽ kiểm tra
trước và kiểu Nếu mà không hợp lệ thì
thông báo lỗi luôn để mở server đỡ phải
kiểm tra anh chỉ có những người ông nào
mà lách được quà không phải ông nào biết
cách làm à lách không ạ thì mình mới
phải kiểm tra bước cuối thôi nhưng mà
thư gan mà ra thằng cũng Nhân tiện đây
nói với thằng Facebook thì thực ra thằng
Facebook kiểm tra vài biết ở server lại
rất là yếu xảy ra ở rất nhiều ông thấy
có trường hợp là tên người dùng nhập
được tên kí tự đặc biệt hai đoạn trích
tên người dùng không có tên không phải
không có TN Chẳng qua người Nhật ký tự
đặc biệt Thành kiểu dấu nó là phải
khoảng không ấy đáng ra nhiều dạng như
tên không có tên đấy có chứa không có
ảnh này vào vần bởi vì thằng thằng
server của Facebook nó đang hạn chế việc
kiểm tra dữ liệu
anh Bởi vì cứ kiểm tra như thế sẽ làm
nặng nặng về việc xử lý vì đôi khi một
hàng muốn xử lý thời gian thực theo kiểu
phản hồi cho người dùng nhanh thì nó sẽ
phải tối ưu việc là làm gì cũng phải trả
về kết quả nhanh ấy ạ ngày ra nó còn ăn
bớt luôn để đoạn kiểm tra
ở server nên nó kiểm tra ở trên máy
người dùng cho nhanh
và đương nhiên là mình sẽ không dạy các
bạn những cái kiểu làm thủ thuật như thế
mình sẽ dạy các bạn từ đầu luôn đó là
kiểm tra trên máy người dùng Nếu mà
người dùng kiểu 01 nợ một lần nữa mình
vẫn sẽ phải kiểm tra lại bằng trên
server trên tất cả trên Pad hoặc sự kiểm
tra Thêm Một Lần Nữa
gì đấy vừa rồi nói sơ qua việc mà là
mình học cái này để làm gì ông ạ Thế bây
giờ mình sẽ đi được bài tập làm luôn
không ạ Mình sẽ làm lại một cái phone
đăng ký Sau đó đi sẽ Varus luôn toàn bộ
những thông tin cho và phong đăng ký đấy
nghĩa người dùng không được phép để
chống này người dùng bắt buộc phải điền
đúng cho nên Vân rất nhiều cái
Ừ mẹ xóa hết đi nó xóa hết cốt củ đi làm
từ đầu
ở đầu tiên thì đương nhiên là Phong đăng
ký phải nằm trong thẻ form nó không ạ
sau đó thì cậu tên này chẳng hạn
như phút
Tech
Nên mình vẫn chưa dùng kia Mình học xong
p mình sẽ dùng nêm này Bây giờ mình
không dùng mình sẽ cho nóng cả ID
tím mình sẽ giải thích tại sao dùng mai
đi có thơ thơ à
Anh tên ở
từ
ngày sinh nhà
bạn ấy sẽ là ID là ngày sinh ngoại
giới tính à input hay Radio này
các bạn nhớ cái vụ Rio này thì lại bắt
buộc phải có nêm Bởi vì nếu mà không có
nêm thì nó sẽ cho chọn được đây
hình mình cho bạn xem luôn kết quả mà gõ
Xong nha
để tránh sự đôi nam
nữ này
nếu mà mình không có nên trùng nhau là
bao nhiêu nó sẽ cậu cho chọn điều kiện
cả hai giới tính cùng một lúc nó ạ thì
cho nó cái nêm đi
về giới tính riêng thằng ngày thì mình
không cho nói đi đâu ạ Mình sẽ chỉ cần
lên như này được rồi mình còn lên như
thế này là phân biệt để mình tím lấy cái
nút thay A có in bút nên theo nêm là
được
ừ ừ
à à
ờ ờ
suy tính có
khi con gì nhé
Em email chẳng nhận được email
Push
email im
add ID email đi
và mật khẩu cho anh ạ
password này
hay đi lại mật khẩu à
à à
để
mình thử cho 10 salad Ôsin nó bạn dễ
hình dung nhé Đăng ký vào lớp đây sẽ
select options And I
khi bật trình
và
bảo mật trong mạng à
ấn
vào đây sẽ có một nút là nút đương nhiên
là đăng ký đó ngoại này này nếu cái nút
Bất Tận như thế này mặc định trong for
mình nó sẽ là thay nó sẽ là sắp ít đúng
không ạ Các bạn nhiều không ạ
là như thế này Ok một form của mình khi
mà mình đi ăn xong hết thông tin chẳng
hạn như này không ạ mình điên hết thông
tin thế này Và thậm chí ở mình không
điều mình cần nút đăng ký nó vẫn nhận
được luôn các bạn hãy nó nói lại cha như
này tất cả mà đang nhận trả qua đó Đang
chưa hiển thị thông báo là thành công
hay thất bại cái gì đó thôi nhưng mà nó
cứ load lại trang như thế này các bạn
hình dung ra nhận rồi cái này ra đang
say mọi việc như mình đã nói đó khi mọi
người dùng không điền đầy đủ thông tin
tại mình không được cho bấm nút đăng ký
không ạ có bạn thì sẽ bảo là
Ừ Ok em cho đoạn này free quite thì nó
sẽ bắt buộc phải điền nữa đúng không ạ
Các bạn nhớ không ạ thì thứ nhất à khi
mình Họ ra Switch để Làm vedette thì
mình không nên dùng cái qua được làm gì
cả Bởi vì à Cái qua mà đúng Hồi đấy tôi
cũng lười vai bếp và ra quyết tôi cứ để
đi qua để bắt buộc phải điền như này bởi
vì HT mà nó hỗ trợ mà nhưng mà do là cái
hiển thị của 2 team lời như thế này các
bạn thấy ạ đang hết toàn tiếng Việt nhà
tự nhiên hiển thị ra tiếng Anh trong nó
trải nghiệm với tôi này Đây là do trình
duyệt tôi đang dùng học tiếng Anh mà
thường này đúng là như thế Nhiều bông
không biết cài trình duyệt thành tiếng
Việt đâu chẳng hạn thế kết hợp việc là
nó hiển thị thông báo đôi khi mà nó chỉ
mức tương đối rồi nó hơn nó là kéo Ê bà
không được để chấm vân vân chữ nó không
kiểm tra được miễn cái hiểu mình muốn là
ví dụ à Tên phải nhập đúng theo cậu là
phải chữ cái đầu viết hoa giống như rùng
mình dùng ghét không Trước nó nhọn cũng
như là Email Email thì mai thằng này hỗ
trợ email nó bắt buộc phải nhập Đúng rồi
nếu còn mật khẩu ra mật khẩu nhà mình
nói chung là sẽ cần dùng gạch ở một vài
chỗ chẳng hạn thế
Ừ thì mình làm như thế nào đúng ạ hoa
Định tôi có những cái mình sẽ hỗ trợ lực
tương đối giống như là cả ngày sinh này
mình có thể dùng mạng kèm min max của
thằng HCl hỗ trợ thì không cho để không
cho việc nhập không Ngày sinh không
chuyện sinh vào ngày mai ông ạ tôi không
đến từ tương lai ở đây cái cờ thế và
nhịn đấy mắt của nó có thể mình can
thiệp như thế nhờ mình cứ thử can thiệp
Thế bảo g-switch định thông báo lỗi ở
đây thì như thế nào Ngoại
lại vừa nói trường hợp với ông Chánh bắt
bẻ được à
Ừ cái này làm ở HTML được mà không mình
chúng ta ở đây không làm thế
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ để tiếng Việt nó vẫn nhỉ ý tiếng Anh
hình như là cả trình duyệt và cả ngôn
ngữ máy của ông để tiếng Việt thì may ra
nói gì thì tiếng Việt thì vậy và đã bìa
cái này còn tùy theo kỳ theo trình duyệt
nữa theo kiểu là trình duyệt mỗi hình
giờ thì nó hiển thị thông báo lỗi Xem
mục kiểu
anh Thành A hơi bị khó chịu để hình a ạ
Mà ông biết vụ ion thì như nào
có ai test mày không nghe
ừ ừ
anh ạ ở tòa nhà đúng không ạ
hình ảnh trong xấu
xe tải Nó kiểu như thế nào kiểu trải
nghiệm người dùng công nghệ tốt cái đoạn
đấy dạ mình thay vì như thế mình sẽ hiển
thị ra kiểu thông báo lỗi ở ngay bên như
thế này nó sẽ ổn hơn
à Nhưng cái quan trọng ở đây đó là
nó nó nó lại phải toán như này khi bấm
nút thì mình sẽ One Click khi bấm nút
này mình mình sẽ gọi đến cái Hàn là hạt
kiểm tra đúng không ạ kiểm tra à
Ừ
thì mình sẽ có ra Swift à
clip này
tạo một cái fan sân đã kiểm tra không ạ
Toàn chất là mình giả sử mình cứ vơ đét
trước thằng tên lại nhé mình sẽ là nét
tên bằng đó của mình ghét em mình body
tên Maru lấy cái tên mình nhập về lịch
sử là tên không được phép để chồng nó ạ
Tức là độ dài của chuỗi tên ạ không đều
bằng 0 là được Tạm thời như thế ít
tên chấm nem là độ dài của chỗ tên bằng
bằng không được ạ đó là sự nha Minh sẽ
thường là tôi sẽ chơi theo cách như này
thường là tôi sẽ có thường có một cái
thẻ span ở bên cạnh
em ở bên cạnh như thế này
Ừ tôi sẽ để mà hiển thị lỗi bé cách
thường thường thấy nhất kiểu thường hay
mình sẽ có span báo lỗi ngay bên cạnh
như thế này sẽ có 1 span đây này Ai đi
ra Euro tên này có thưởng này để như này
Ừ cái này tôi để tiếng Anh Hùng Tí Hon
bé uống để chỗ tiếng Việt thì nó sẽ lỗi
tay ngay không ạ
Như này và
khi khi mà như thế này mình sẽ đó của
mình
Ừ cái này blue switch
mình sẽ lỗi tên này chấm bi nơ HTML là
cái tên không được để chấm này à
em làm gì này nó chạy thử Đấy bấm này
đúng thấy là nó vừa bị lại chữ rất là
nhanh rồi nó chớp nhoáng rồi nó bị vẫn
vẫn đẩy cái này đi mất Tại sao lại như
thế bởi vì như tội nói thì đó là khi bấm
vào thì nó vỡ sắp ít không ạ Các bạn
không thể đổ cái này bút Tân Thành 2 bút
thần được mà các bạn nên vẫn vẫn nên để
nó xem ít
anh Bởi vì bản chất cái nút này mà mình
sẽ dùng ra Speed để năm cái việc là cái
Ừ cái form mà được đẩy đi nó sẽ ổn hơn
nó sẽ như sau sẽ ăn gì sao mình sẽ có
khái niệm Nitơ này như thế này và và đây
mình sẽ nếu mà khi mà không được để mà
khi mà có lỗi gì đó anh sẽ Return là
Phone này à
em còn nếu mà không đi tầm đây nó sẽ
hiểu gì Tôi là Chu không ạ 01 Return thì
nó sẽ hiểu gì tôi mà chu thích thì mình
đi như thế này cũng được nó không không
có được
đây để các bạn xem thử nhé
anh bấm này đó các bạn thấy phòng không
được xem nghị nữa không ạ hiển thị ra
được ờ
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây nó sẽ có một nhược điểm
một tí đó là sao đó là ở
thì các bạn kiểm tra bao nhiêu cái đây
thì các bạn sẽ gì Tên bấy nhiêu cái đấy
Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là
Ừ nếu mà giả sử Nếu bây giờ sử mà các
bạn bị sai lỗi chính tả ra sửa đây khiến
mất cái chấm phẩy như này thôi chẳng ạ
bấm này
Vì sao đây vẫn nhận
ở đây tôi sai chính tả đây nhé len là sự
đi sai chính tả đi vậy
em chẳng phải đi sang thả thôi nhé bấm
đây
Ê mày không thấy iPhone rồi xem ít đúng
ạ ạ Thế nên là cách làm để mà các bạn
tránh làm việc là không biết đường mình
sai ngay đây tôi cho mấy ông xem nhé bấm
vào đây nó hiển thị lỗi rất nhanh sông
nó xem ít xử mất rồi thành thành ra là
cậu có ông không nhìn được lỗi công cứ
tưởng cốt ông chạy được chạy đúng có
đúng Tại sao kiểu bấm vào đây nó không
bị lỗi không ạ Đấy thì cách để mà như
này nhớ nhất là một là mấy ông đổi kẻ
bước chân lại thành phố tuần trước để mà
Mấy ông kéo biết được à cốt mình đang
chạy đồng và đang say
ông thầy nó không ba lỗ luôn đấy
ờ ờ
anh không báo lỗi không ạ Đây
I il take in thật Đỡ thế nhỉ À thì tại
sao lại không báo lỗi nhé hay là không
vào được luôn anh nhé
Anh bình thường nó sẽ báo lỗi không tìm
thấy cái hàng này cơ nhưng chắc à có vẻ
là nó không báo lỗi kiểu nghe chứ không
sao ạ
có cách cách để có ông biết được xem có
lỗi không ấy thì béo có thể xóa sử cái
đoạn cút một đoạn Cốt nó đi giờ sử về
sau cốt mình sẽ rất là dài tận mấy trăm
dòng ấy mấy ông có thể là
điện nó hình Chú thích kiểu ngay điều mà
chạy thử mình sẽ con solo chùm lót này
vụ tai nạn chạy thơ từng cái một
à à
anh như này với các bạn biết được cái
xem nó có chạy được hay không lại gõ tên
Nga đó chạy được nghe Chứng tỏ là đến
cái đoạn đoạn nào đó họ sẽ sai ở một chỗ
nào đó đúng ạ thì mình mình kiểu bò bỏ
dần chú thích bỏ dần chú thích mình sẽ
biết được
khi sex
cho tôi tôi thường hay làm cách kiểu
ngay in đẩy cái hàng có slot này nó đến
đến dần dần mình cái đoạn nào đó là sử
nó đến cái đoạn này họ cảm nó đến đoạn
này được ạ Nói thử anh chơi ngay thằng
này tôi sẽ để cả Không nghe trong trường
hợp mà ở đâu trường hợp một người đúng
chứ Tôi muốn nó nhảy vào đây thì nó sẽ
ra số 1 Nếu em nhảy xuống cái chỗ không
số không này đúng ạ
Ừ thì nó nó sẽ là sai không ạ
à à
I live and the force không không trong
trường hợp này không có gì further phố ở
đâu
chỉ vì yêu mà đến cuối rồi cho form bằng
sắp ít đúng
anh không Tôi muốn cho mấy ông ấy hiểu
bản chất luôn cả cái dùng get Ơn trời vì
à on on toilet thì kết hợp Return cửa
nhà được
đề thi khi nói chung là giả sử cốt ở đây
lỗi không Tôi có một cách thì kiểm tra
lỗi
anh không tôi cố tình gõ ngày lỗi đúng
không Thì cách để kiểm tra lỗi thì nếu
mới để chơi cách kiểu ngay nó dậy in ra
Em in ra 12 inch không hiểu nhà kiểm tra
A bấm nhanh nhẹn béo ngậy nữa số 0 tức
là cốt là không chạy đây đúng không Thì
có mới kiểm tra xem lại cái điều kiện là
đúng hay sai
Ở đây chẳng hạn thế còn đấy bây giờ gõ
đúng chỗ nào Bấm và này đó thì nó ra một
đúng không ạ Lúc này trong trường hợp
này thì béo mà biết được đấy cách thì đi
bốc cốt đầu tiên các bạn sẽ bùi bùi chủ
thích cho sau đó đi chạy lần lượt từng
cái xe mà đến đến được cái dòng nào đó
ngọn bởi vì a cốt các bạn không những
sai ở một lòng mà say đôi khi ở rất
nhiều dòng mình từng mình từng bị như
thế Mình hiểu mà mình hiểu cảm giác mà
mình sai có khí dai ngay dòng thứ hai ấy
mấy dòng ruồi rất là đúng hết nhưng xoay
dòng thứ hai là một cốt kiểu không chạy
nữa
cho nên là các bạn sẽ thứ nhất là các
bạn sẽ phải không cho form sắp ít đi bởi
vì ra Switch mà nó nhưng như thế này chị
sẽ chết này bọn đấy Thành nha các bạn sẽ
phải
bọn một là đổi thay nó bước thật như thế
này đây một cách có bạn bảo kênh kia
dùng live defo cũng được hoa cà Tôi làm
hội đấy có cách đơn giản hơn tôi tạm
chấp nhận là xóa cái phần for mày đi trở
lại lẽ tạm thời tạm thời Xóa đi
vi phạm thuế xóa đi để mà mình bấm vào
như này nó sẽ không Không vấn đề gì Nếu
các bạn Sai đúng for nó sẽ không dám ít
nóng bạn
à à
Ừ cái vụ Tôi dùng cái glitter để vợ đi
Tân Phone này tôi sẽ giải thích cho mấy
ông Tại sao tội dùng đây Bởi vì nếu mà
giả sử bây giờ có nhiều trường hợp và
việc và mình kiểm tra trống không phải
mỗi tên nữa mà Ngày sinh nói chung kiểm
tra sống tất cả những hoài nha đầu tiên
tôi cứ tạo ra đây một đống nhá
Tạo đây một đồng đi
xin lỗi ngày sinh nhật hạ không ạ
lỗi giới tính rồi ạ nó sửa ngay
ạ
sau đó thì mình kiểm tra về ngày sinh
này ạ
nhớ
ngày sinh cho sư tử như ngày sinh chấm
đen Cũng được đấy ạ
anh ta lỗi Ngày sinh không ạ à à
ừ ừ
đó là sự chạy thử cho đã Anh tên có một
để chống lại ừ chúng tỏ ngày sinh này
đang có vấn đề Anh thử con solo chấm Lót
cái ngày sinh ra xem Tại sao nhé
bấm này
a a luôn ở đây Ở đây đang bị khói không
bị nhược điểm một tí đó là ở đây mình
ghi tên phone mất rồi
a
written for thành ra là là nó sẽ kết
thúc kể Tăng Trần ngay tại kẻ glitter
này thành ra là nó không nhảy xuống cái
đoạn kiểm tra ngày sinh nữa các bạn đang
thấy ở đây rõ ràng ngày sinh của mình
đang chấm nó ạ nhưng mà không ghi thông
báo lỗi bởi vì
nó không nó không chạy đến cái cái cái
dòng này bởi vì đây written full rồi cái
cách để mà
các bạn muốn hiển thị ra một là các bạn
cứ để lỗi các bạn dừng ngay cả đấy bạn
hiền thì lỗi luôn như thế này sau đó lên
người dùng điền tiếp nha chẳng hạn thì
bắt đầu hiển thị lỗi ở dòng tiếp theo
hay là các bạn muốn hiển thị toàn bộ tất
cả các lỗi luôn để người dùng điền đầy
đủ cho người dùng bấm thì nó cũng sẽ hợp
lý hơn thì các bạn sẽ sẽ có khái niệm là
các bạn sẽ tại một biến ở đây mình sẽ
tạo biến là biến nhà
kiểm tra lỗi em ạ
lúc đầu mình sẽ cho bằng chu được ạ Lúc
đầu mình cho phone em ạ ạ Sau đó cứ mỗi
lần mà thằng này có
thai có lỗi thật thì mình sẽ cho nó vẫn
chui rằng ạ thế này
à à
ạ
và ở cuối mình sẽ kiểm tra nếu mà kiểm
tra lỗi là đúng nó ngoác đi nghị một là
các bạn sẽ So sánh kiểu nhà bằng bằng
bằng chu như này hòa các bạn đi Tắt cả
ngày cũng được vì bạn chất À cái này là
nó Chu rồi thì tất cả các điều kiện này
đúng là đúng ạ thì mình sẽ là Return
phone như thế này còn nếu không đi Tôn
thì như mình đã nói không Peter thì mặc
định nó sẽ Britain's luôn
bấm vào ngay nó sẽ in ra được cả hai cả
luôn không ạ Đấy cách để mình sẽ kiểm
tra mình sẽ tạo ra một cái biến cá tra
lỗi Sau đó mình sẽ làm lương dân như thế
này
à à
ờ ờ
anh ở đây mình
anh ở đây mình kiểm tra tên được ra kiểm
tra tên Ở đây mức tương đối là tên không
được đấy chấm nếu mà mình không kết hợp
với led hôm trước đây mình giờ sửa mình
kết hợp với Gas không trước nhé
ghét hôm trước tôi không dạy lại cái vụ
được cái không trước đâu nghe Tôi sẽ chỉ
dùng Nhanh cái mà tôi đã lưu chẳng lại
cho nhanh
em thật sự đây à họ tên đi
em
copy cái đoạn này trên anh ạ
Ờ
thì đầu tiên à mình sẽ tạo một cái và
đôi rách tên rồi ạ
bằng xốp chéo như thế này copy các loại
này 3A
Ừ thì Dallas tên nhớ cách để kiểm tra để
kiểm tra cái này thì sẽ đúng như cái
dùng từ mình kiểm tra ạ
cho tôi cứ cách hẳn ra một dòng nha mấy
ông dễ hình dung nhé sẽ tên này có
thương anh đi kiểu nhà cho mấy ông cậu
dễ Hình dung là phân biệt thằng ạ Thằng
này là ngày mấy thằng kia không ạ đề thi
3 cách để kiểm tra việc Tên nó hợp lệ
hay không thì mình sẽ là ít à tên chấm
test
ạ sau đó đi về este này
đúng là tôi tôi nhớ là thằng thằng nào
trước là sau tôi xin phép cha Google lại
phát nữa
em không nhớ lắm
em à ngược lại ngược lại
ở lại đấy nghe rồi rách tên test
Nếu mà đúng
nếu mà ngược lại cái đúng nghĩa nếu ạ
Nếu mà sai không ạ thì các bạn bằng bằng
phone là sai đúng không ạ
ở đó
Ừ thì mình sẽ in a là
Anh tên không hợp lệ Hằng ạ
hạ thế
Ừ cái này thời gian nó bị nhược điểm một
tí đó và tên không được để trống rồi hãy
còn nhảy sang tên không hợp lệ nữa nó
nhọn nên là mấy ông có thể kiểm tra ít
như này trước em như này
to như thế này nghĩa là chi mà
sau khi mà kiểu tên không được để trống
rồi nếu bắt đầu kiểm tra tế trước sau
sau đó đến việc
mình kiểm tra xem tên có hợp lệ không nó
thì này nóng chuẩn hơn này
a a sáng đó tôi không hợp lệ chẳng hạn
thế đúng ạ có cách cách này thời ra béo
có thể viết tắt hơn nữa nhé đó các bạn
để rồi Tham nào trước như thế này Cái
thằng này trong lập trình nó sẽ hiểu là
ngược nó là ngược lại mà giống dấu trừ
với
AE theo kiểu nó ngược lại để lặng tất cả
kiểu chu sẽ thành phone phone là sẽ làm
chuyển ạ Cái này kiểm tra đây tôi sẽ chú
thích chồng mấy ông sẽ đây sẽ ra băng
băng phone không ạ nghe thì sẽ viết theo
kiểu ngược lại kiểu như thế này cái này
phone ngược lại hình chu mà không ạ Đây
kiểu viết
Ừ thôi tôi đang dạy cho mấy ông cả các
ký tự nữa để mà để mà Mấy ông à về sau
mà xem cốt có hỗ trợ lâu đấy về mày
không còn hình dung được không lại bảo
tôi không dậy được cái đấy đúng rồi nó
phủ định nóng dùng từ chuẩn đấy thôi
quên mất cái từ đấy nó phủ định lại thì
nên là cái iPhone thì nó sẽ phủ định lại
nên Chu đúng không ạ là người lại
Ừ đúng rồi nó chỉ tác dụng với bao lần
gì vậy mà không tác dụng với
tôi Tôi chưa thử cái chuỗi ngày các thứ
thứ
nhưng mà hình như là với chỗ nghỉ cho
ở chỗ ấy thì hình như nó ngược lại nó sẽ
luôn hay là lại Phone xe 7 chỗ nào luôn
là Chu mà Trừ khi chỗ ông ở chỗ trống
à à
à à đầy tiếp theo là đến bên
bên Giới Tính giới tính thì các bạn sẽ
thấy phức tạp hơn một tí giới tính thì
mình không để bắt buộc người ta bắt buộc
phải chọn Nam được không thể bắt buộc
phải ra sẵn nữ được đúng ạ Mình chỉ quan
tâm việc là họ có chọn một trong hai
không ngồi đó ngọn hết cách thì mà
3 cách để mình kiểm tra xem họ có trọn
bộ trong hay không thì đó là mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ phải cần lấy cả hai hàng về
sau đó em kiểm tra xem họ đã tích và cái
này họ chỉ cần tích là một trong hai cái
tức là tớ ám chỉ thành công nó ạ nếu ra
sự cả hai cái mà họ được không thích thì
sẽ định là thất bại không ạ Cái cách để
mà lấy mình sẽ lấy cả hai cái về nó sẽ
bằng led Giới Tính
giới tính lần này nó sẽ sẽ số nhiều
thường mình sẽ đặt tên nó ai bởi nó
xuống nhiều tên nó làm mạc như chính
ngay đây sẽ bằng đo cung đó của mình
Chấm ghét em mình bye nêm này giới tính
này à Ê
bà các bạn sẽ thấy ở mình sẽ không có
chấm value ở đây Tại sao bởi việc trong
trường hợp lần này các bạn sẽ thấy nó có
khác một tí nhé em mình body thì nó sẽ
không có chữ S Tức là nó số ít không ạ
con ghẹ em mình thêm chữ s này ăn chỉ
nói sao về mạng mà nó sẽ rồi Nhiều mà
mình sẽ chạy vòng lặp các bạn nhiều vòng
lặp không ạ Mình sẽ là for này Nét y
bằng không Này y nhỏ hơn
nhỏ hơn mạnh giới tính chấm e này lại
theo độ dài của mạng gửi tính đi cộng
này
và
sau đó thì mình sẽ kiểm tra với mảng
giới tính tại vị trí Thử
Y mình sẽ tạo một biến là biển à
em kiểm tra dự tính đi
bằng Phone này à
cho mình mình sẽ phải tại một biến thể
kiểm tra dự tính xem mà nó là thích nghe
chưa Sau đó thì nếu mà ít
tại thẻ mạng giới tính tại vị trí tùy nó
là tích cực thế này là được
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra
giới tính mình sẽ ảnh Chu tất cả mình
được tích rồi ông ạ và đây mình kiểm tra
nếu mà kiểm tra giới tính bằng bằng
phone tất cả chưa đầu tích gì cả đó thì
mình mới thông báo lỗi lỗi giới tính
à à
xin lỗi Giờ tình không ạ là giới tính
không được để chấm em ạ
Ở nhà hay
The Bells sự tích là này
thì tại sao nhé sự tích rồi
khi đó Tại sao mấy ông thấy tôi vừa rồi
phải tại trang bởi vịt Bây giờ xử tôi
điền hết toàn bộ như này
em đang chúng ta lại sang từ đầu mà ông
xem nhé
Ừ nếu thấy là nó không thể xóa cái lỗi
cũ đi đúng ạ thì các bạn sẽ phải e ở đây
nghĩa là khi mà nó thành công rồi mình
sẽ phải xóa lỗi đi dù không ạ thì đây
đợt đầu tiên thì đây mình sẽ ra
anh
với đoạn tên này thì mình kiểm tra nếu
mà thành công thằng này
ô t có được để trống này tên Nói chung
là đoạn này Thành công hết này sẽ e ở
đây đó là
à à
thì mình sẽ xóa mình sẽ xóa cái á
Ê mày đi cho nó những chỗ trống để hiểu
được là
đây là sự lúc đầu tiên không được để
trống nhé Đừng Gọi cho Long này đó hợp
lệ luôn không ạ thì gọi chữ a a tên 01
lệ này gõ chữ này tên không hợp lệ đấy
ai biết hoa này hợp lệ đấy đúng không ạ
Đấy thì cái mê Cái dưới này tương tự Thế
Các bạn thấy Cốt nó cũng sẽ bao dày dần
dần dần lên nó sẽ như thế này à
xin
lỗi
ngày sinh nhật hạnh không ạ Lúc đầu lỗi
này chọn một cái ngày sinh nào đó đó thì
sẽ đi vào cái này tương tự thế
à à
có
ai sẽ phá ra các bạn sẽ thấy công nhận
nó sẽ ra à
em dấu tích xanh nhà dấu tích xanh thì
bạn chất nó là
nó là CS các bạn sẽ chèn thêm một cái
biểu tượng ở trên mạng các bạn thể tải
tại cái ảnh ảnh này hoặc là cái biểu
tượng mới về Đúng cái xé đấy về để có
bạn Hiển thị nó ra thôi chứ nó không gì
đặc biệt cả các bạn thở ra các bạn có
thể làm theo nhiều cách là các bạn có
thể bôi màu đỏ
3 other models cho ngày input nào mà
không hợp lệnh hạn chế Nãy giờ tôi đang
làm thì thực ra mấy cái lỗi này các bạn
có thể thêm class cho nó một ra thêm
Glass 2 toàn bộ spam nó thành
colourglass cũng được nhưng thường tôi
sẽ cho nó class class là span lỗi chẳng
hạn như này em có Slow tôi sẽ có style
cho nó
là với Star lỗi mình sẽ color splash em
ạ ạ
thế này
ở Đông ạ Mẹ chồng thưởng ngay à
Ừ tí bạn về cái vụ
anh không cần sắp ít mà nó vẫn chạy vào
cái eo không chẳng qua mình bấm lại lần
nữa thì nó sẽ chạy lại về phương trình
này thì nó kiểm tra lại thêm một lượt
nữa mà thấy hợp lễ hết tình nó chạy và
eo thôi ông ạ
khi mà thực ra là thực tế là
cái vụ hiển thị ra thông báo thành công
các thứ thứ nếu mà nếu trong trường hợp
mà các bạn Nhập xong hết tiền đúng là
năng ký rồi đó nó nhảy lên luôn chứ nó
không không cần nói mất công vợ xóa mấy
cái này và thông báo thành công không
thông báo tích xanh ở đây em gì nữa
không ạ ạ
em có bạn cũng có thể thắc mắc cả vụ là
em đang muốn là kiểu em em Điền đến cái
đoạn này nó sẽ thông báo luôn à phải
điền cái ở trên tên không được để chấm
nóng hoặc những những cái đấy là ra bài
toán phức tạp hơn một tí theo kiểu là
người dùng Điền đến đây và nó sẽ thông
nó sẽ kiểm tra trước những cái hầm trên
của nó không ạ để mặc để mở cậu thông
báo lỗ luôn nhé người dùng gõ đến đâu
kiểm tra nhìn Đấy cũng là một cách không
ạ Như cái này nó phức tạp hơn thì mình
sẽ không dạy ở đây các bạn muốn tìm hiểu
thì các bạn tìm hiểu về cái thực có
nhiều thư viện của Switch để mà làm vụ
virus rất là nhanh các bạn tra Google nó
sẽ ra và Days a Switch nó sẽ cho ra cả
cốt mẫu các bạn có hoa cả thư viện thư
viện Tức là sao nghĩa là ra Cốc rất
nhiều dòng cốt thận chỉ nhìn dòng ngồi
chẻ làm pate cho các bạn để các bạn chỉ
cần nhúng hay thư viện này về là nó sẽ
hỗ trợ ở xin lỗi này bà kết hợp dùng
rách này các thứ để mà hiển thị ra cậu
người ta gõ đến đâu ấy thông báo tên quá
ngắn này tên không đủ dày vân vân cũng
được thì mình mình không dậy các bạn ở
mượn mấy cái mức đấy
Em à mình chỉ dạy các bạn hiểu thế nào
là virus cũng nhờ lập trình các tự rồi
đúng không ạ
tiếp theo vụ Email Email Thật ra như
mình đã nói nếu có lợn dùng thay mail
như thế này thì ra Hà Tĩnh l nó hỗ trợ
để một người dùng bắt bụi đúng rồi nên
các bạn cùng đón mà bạn chỉ cần kiểm tra
đây là là
Ừ nó nó bắt buộc phải điền thôi nó ngon
Ừ nhưng mà tôi khuyên mấy ông nên vẫn đi
dùng có thì bảo đã Nếu thế thì em vẫn
muốn dùng mà vui rách để mà kiểm tra thì
sao ạ Em em đổi cái này hành tách sau đó
Thì em kiểm tra bằng bằng giao tiếp được
không Thì ra tôi khuyên Nếu mà không nên
như thế có những cái gì mình vẫn phải
nên giữ nguyên như thế này Tại sao bởi
vì nó giống như kiểu ông ông cũng có ông
bảo là kiểu em bắt ở đây Nhập tuổi em ạ
sử Thế nhá là sự thôi nhé Đây nhiêu tuổi
rồi hạn tôi sau đó thì em để tách thay
vì để nằm bờ sau đó em sẽ dùng ra quyết
để để bạn lưu ý Kiểm tra Thì sao Thì cái
này khuyên không nên Tại sao vì
ơi
các bạn hãy nên nhớ điều đó là
cho người dùng các bạn bây giờ còn dùng
bằng điện thoại nữa
Thế nên là cái vụ Cái vụ mà kiểu nhiễm
và các bạn thay đổi kể thay bút thành
Tech thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra cái bàn phím
gọi điện thoại là có chữ còn nếu mà thay
nó là Email thì nó sẽ được gợi ý tự động
điền của điện thoại cũng như là thay
bằng năm bờ thì nó sẽ hiển thị bàn phím
số của điện thoại người dùng sẽ dễ tiền
hơn tôi phải nói vụ đấy vì đã có nhiều
chàng ngu si ai kia rõ ràng là cái ô
nhập số điện thoại nhưng mà nó lại để
thay Thái tách hãy ra cho người dùng
điền số điện thoại rất là mệt cần phải
bấm hai cái nick để đổi sang bàn phím số
cũng là nó không có gợi ý của số điện
thoại điền số điện thoại ạ Bây giờ là
trình duyệt nó cũng thông minh nó sẽ gợi
ý vụ tự động Điền nên là Nên là các bạn
để nên nó lại ID nói cho mọi thứ Nếu
tiếng Anh thì cái vụ tự động điền của
cái trình duyệt nó sẽ hiểu nó sẽ tự động
Điền rất là ổn Còn nếu các bạn để tiếng
Việt cũng như là các bạn để hết bằng hai
tách thì nó sẽ tự động điền giá là đểu
để không ạ
Ê mấy ông để ý kĩ một cái vụ tự động
điền của cái trình duyệt mong sẽ hiểu là
do là do kệ trang đấy nó đều như thế nào
thì tự động Điền không hiểu cái gì cả
đúng không ạ
Ừ nếu ông khó chịu ở vụ đấy và mấy ông
từng là người dùng đúng ạ bây giờ mấy
ông sang Làm lập trình rồi đúng không ạ
Nếu không phải rút kinh nghiệm từ những
người đi trước để mà tránh những cái cái
khó chịu ấy chảy ra không phải bắt chước
đâu nhé Ngoài thể lừa rồi bắt chưa rồi
nhé em
mà tôi từng vào tôi từng bảo tôi vào cái
trang
của Vietcombank sau đó thì ra Speed với
đã đều nó không cho tôi có điền đầy đủ
thông tin từ đăng ký âm được đi nên tôi
bực mình thôi mở ra Swift lên để tôi tự
gõ thì xăm ít được cái phom đấy là Nhạn
đấy thì tôi mới cậu khó chịu ở viện
nhiều trang lớn nó làm tệ như thế nào
à à
Ừ cái vụ Email thì
chắc cả nó cũng chỉ là không được để
trống cho tôi bỏ qua nhé Thôi chả làm vụ
mật khẩu thôi vụ mật khẩu thì nó còn
thêm với vụ là mình không được để quá
ngắn ạ ạ Thế Mong cái hay mở ngoặc ạ
Em email tạm bỏ qua đi em ạ
Ừ
tôi sẽ còn nhắc đến lại Nó cho anh khi
nào nó ổn thì thôi ạ bây giờ nó vẫn đều
vãi này là tôi không thể không Rồi nó ra
được Ông ta
là Mật khẩu này và lưu cho em ạ
sau đó mình kiểm tra mật khẩu
chấm le này
Ừ nếu mà ngắn ngắn hơn à
ở đầu tiên là giả sửa Mio muốn bắt thêm
các trường hợp với kiểu không được để
trống rồi ngắn quá Cái gì đó Con kiểm
tra về độ mạnh của mật khẩu thì
hôm trước anh Tuấn Anh ấy cũng chia sẻ
có nhiều Trang nó nó có chia sẻ mấy cái
đoạn Quý khách có trong đó có cả đấy
cách kiểm tra về độ mạnh mật khẩu là
phải có kí tự đặc biệt trong đó Tấm đơn
Vân thì các bạn tra Google sẽ có ngay
Tôi ghét password có có ra Speed luôn
này Đấy rất tiện không ạ cho tôi tôi tôi
chia sẻ từ khóa thì thôi để mấy ông
Thạch hạ thôi
Xin
lỗi mình sẽ có tạo một cái spam Ở Đây
Rồi cá hồi để tôi bị khó chịu ở điểm là
tạo làm span Vãi cả thế
thật à Khởi đấy tôi còn nghĩ ra cách để
đó là
cứ thằng nào mà lỗi in bút thì mình sẽ
tự tạo tự dùng dao Swift để mà tạo một
cái HTML ở bên cạnh cài than I put đấy
và tạo span cũ cũng cũng được kiểu đấy
cũng được
ở bài thích thì tôi thử làm mẫu cho mấy
ông một quả này nhá cũng được nhé Thì
mấy ông sẽ thấy là nó cũng ổn như nào
đây tôi sẽ như thế trong trường hợp này
tôi xóa này Đây nè
Đây là một cái input 1 họp đúng ạ input
mà khẩu
Nó ghét em mình nhé em ạ
net mật khẩu đến như là mực mật khẩu
value thì nó sẽ ra input mật khẩu chấm
Peru thôi không ạ nhìn này
anh nghe vẫn luôn đúng không ạ nhưng mà
đến cái lỗi ở đây tôi sẽ tôi sẽ làm như
sau tôi sẽ là ờ
cho tôi sẽ tạo một cái
cái HTML cạnh cái thằng cái thằng Mật
khẩu này
vì thương nhớ nó là offensive là viết
thêm HTML switch
ở bên trai tôi là tạo thằng con mất rồi
xe Open cạnh nó disease
anh Đợi mình tí mình mình chưa làm bằng
da Speed phần bây giờ bình thường Anh
dùng bằng gj hơn đơn vị
Em in static
anh tí thử nhé
Chưa thử sao biết ông ạ
à à
em à Cái này input mật khẩu Này cái có
hàm của nó chắc thế Cái này sẽ spam
không ạ
à à
thì mình sẽ span chữa ngay
em nghe không cần ai đi nữa rảnh lại bỏ
đi bỏ đi Không cần ai đi nữa vào đây sẽ
là giới tính không được mật khẩu không
được để trống không ạ
ờ ờ
bí
mật khẩu không được để trống
thử thì biết không ạ
Hà Nội
bí mật khẩu chấm net à
ở đây mình thử con solo chấm rock thế
nào mật khẩu hãy xem
xem mã lỗi gì à
anh nói chó mà em thử xem nó chạy đều ở
đây không nhé mình lại chạy lần lượt
thôi đúng không ạ sẽ được đây không này
à
có cả một vẫn vào
ở đây mình thử xem inspector ngày tuổi
xem
à À đây nó có tạo như là tạo đây hình
như nó tạo vào bên trong bên trong của
thằng Phúc nó say mất rồi
cách tạo là thằng con mới rồi
hồ sen
à à
a before after
Em in size à đây đây after gaining là
tạo bên bên cạnh ở đằng sau A
anh vẫn không có này xem nha
anh bita
anh after ghi mạnh
a a đây
Tập đọc tập your love you
ông này chạy đấy đó như thế này
có gj nó sẽ giúp cốt dress nó nhanh hơn
và vì nó rút gọn lại những cái này nó sẽ
giúp cốt ra Swift nhanh hơn thôi nhưng
mà các bạn học vì sao vì các bạn thấy gj
nó khá ạ khá là dài dòng kiểu vẫn có thể
nhanh hơn nữa bằng các phê thuốc mà về
cơ bản tư duy nó thư viện rất là nặng
nên thành ra là kiểu về sau không ai
giống mấy
ở đây Các bạn thấy là rõ ràng vừa rồi
Mình đã chơi theo cách riêng nữa đó là
mình có thể dùng Switch để mà tạo ra hầm
cái mặt hpl thì chị lỗi ngay bên cạnh để
mình đỡ ngay từ lúc đầu mình có một cái
span lỗi ở bên này không ạ thì cái này
nhưng mà như này nó sẽ bị nhược điểm nó
sẽ bị nhược điểm đó là kiểu Nếu thế thì
trong trường hợp mà mình nhập Đúng rồi
thì sao thì mình phải xóa cái cũ là đi
đúng không ạ sẽ xóa cái cũ ấy đi sẽ khó
bởi vì vốn dĩ cái này được tạo ra sau
này nghe rất khó là bị xóa với mình thử
cho các bạn một cả ID các bạn sẽ thấy
hình dung này
xin
lỗi mật khẩu nhé
Giờ sự là em ở đây Toàn là đồ ngoại Tèo
đây là
thì mình sẽ làm thì cả ngày gì vẫn như
cũ là mình sẽ lỗ mật khẩu
nhtl mình cháu ông ạ mình cho bạn xem
bí
mật khẩu điện là bấm máy
thì các bạn thấy lỗi không ạ
có nhanh quá không ạ
thì tại sao vừa tội lỗi nha Thì sẽ lại
Tại sao vô tội lỗi
xe tải
a button ở đây bị xóa đây mưa rồi hãy
một tuần Đấy à
anh bấm này ở này
thì các bạn thấy lỗi ở đây nó bảo lỗi là
không tìm thấy kệ cho comment ghét cái
cái đoạn này nó gây lỗi này nhằm 93 này
tất cả kể cái này chỗ là các bạn vừa mới
dùng ra Swift để sinh ra rồi cái thằng
Có ai đi à nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm ai đi
bằng mới đúng thiếu Thiện Ý
à à
anh ở đây này có vẻ nó vẫn nhận được
chứng tỏ là thằng này chạy ra tạo ra sau
đó thằng này lại được gọi lại nó vẫn
nhận nhưng mà nếu là trong trường hợp
mặt hàng này mà gọi được gọi trước được
gọi trước nhé á
Thì
lúc đầu mình Điền xã mật khẩu như này
bấm vào đây Các bạn thấy lỗi vẫn lỗi bởi
vì rõ ra là thằng này nó không hề được
tạo ra bởi tháng ai
300 tôi vẫn biết tôi đang nói gì mà
Ừ đấy thì thằng này nó không được tạo ra
bởi cái thằng thai được tạo ra khi lỗi
ông ạ con khi thành công thì lại không
được tạo ra thành A thằng này nó vẫn bị
báo lỗi như này là không tồn tại đúng
không ạ
thì các bạn hiểu ý mình ngọn Thế này là
thế nên lúc đầu mình vẫn nên có một cái
thằng tồn tại ở đây không ạ hoặc à lúc
đầu mình vẫn phải nên tồn tại trước sau
đó thì mình cập nhật vào trong Thằng đấy
nó sẽ ổn hơn thì việc tạo ra như này con
chuẩn ra như này chuẩn dạy cho lôgic nó
là lỗi thì tạo ra ông ạ Còn không lỗi
thì phải xóa đi thì nó mới chuẩn Xóa đi
Xóa hẳn nặng Penny Chúng mày Xóa lỗi
HTML của nó thì mới hợp lý thì cái cái
đoạn này thì ra vẫn làm được vẫn làm
được bảo ra Speed là ông vẫn này kiểm
tra span ở bên cạnh cửa hàng input đấy
có hay không ạ sau đó mình xóa các fan
đấy đi vẫn được nhưng nói chung nhà cốt
bằng ra sweep thì nó sẽ ra lòng bằng gia
công nhận ở trong nó vẻ ngắn gọn hơn sau
khi nào tôi sẽ dạy cho cao ông về tí ri
sau nhờ vấn đề về sau dậy sau
bí ngô Vừa rồi tôi mới để mua qua cho
ông đi ông ấy mấy cái vụ này mày ông
hình nhớ lại việc là HTML có thể được
sinh ra mở ra Speed đoạn ở đây tôi kiểm
tra thêm một phát nữa đi Tôi muốn kiểm
tra là mật khẩu chấm đen giờ sự là không
được phép ngắn hơn 8 ký tự được ạ Không
ạ sẽ báo lỗi tiếp đi nó sẽ như thế nào
tôi sẽ đeo cuối này đoạn này nếu mà vẫn
lỗi thì nó sẽ ra như thế nào ạ
à à
Ừ thôi tôi cứ vứt cài span lỗi ở trên
trên này cho chuẩn nhé lỗi mật khẩu
ừ ừ
cho ví dụ không Nhập hai lần thì nó có
sinh ra hai cái spam không
Ừ Ừ hình như nó sẽ sinh ở 2 span Đấy
bấm này bấm vào tiếp này đúng rồi nó
sinh ra đúng rồi nó có kiểm tra việc
span đã tồn tại đâu Thế bạn kia nói thôi
mình nhớ ra đấy
Ở đây còn chết nữa không ạ bởi vì mình
không thể kiểm tra đúng không ạ Mình
không kiểm tra gì cả nên thôi chúng nhớ
là cái này nó không phù hợp đúng ạ
ở tại Xóa đi thôi
Anh
đổi mật khẩu này à
ừ ừ
à à
em
hiểu nha bạn ấy
bí mật khẩu không nên để chấm như thế
này
đi hái
cho anh kiểu Nga
ở đâu ạ bây ở trong trường hợp mà mình
đi đầy đủ hết thì mình sẽ cho phom gửi
đi thôi ông ạ
cả các tổ chưa chỉ cho bạn kia vụ và tôi
còn chửi bạn tôi bằng
bằng tin cốt nhưng mà kết hợp với cả
ngôn à gọi nhé
bộ mã hóa
cô gái tôi thường anh chửi bạn tôi đó là
đi em cốt
bay64 này cái Tại sao dùng bây giờ từ vì
cái này có thể giải được cốt khá ông
đừng có những cái kiểu mã hóa nó phức
tạp quá không dài được
cho tôi sẽ thường ai kiểu trẻ
Á Châu
họ Hihi đồ ngốc trở lại ngày xưa thế sợ
and cốt này nó sẽ ra xinh nha các bạn
này ngon
sau đó không Không những thế Tôi còn tạo
phím tắt cho nó Tôi sẽ có cái bộ gõ gõ
tìm việc tôi đây đúng không Mà cậu tắt
này hoặc nó sẽ thay thế từ tôi gõ từ như
thế này nó sẽ như này thêm này lưu lại
đấy Sau đó thì cũng mỗi lần tôi gọi chứ
này nó sẽ ra đó thôi tôi sẽ chửi bọn nó
bằng cái từ đây tôi tôi có một đống phím
tắt này Ở trên điện thoại tôi cơ kể trên
mạch máy vừa rồi Ông thấy à có tắt nữa
tôi trên này ít còn trên điện thoại của
tôi đây Đầy gõ tắt chửi nhau bằng tin
cốt nhưng mà được mã hóa mấy cái thang
mà muốn xem tôi
Anh xem tôi hiểu nói gì lại phải mất
công lấy mạng để ngồi dịch lại dịch lại
thấy mình chửi nó thế ấy rất là trai
không hiểu
hãy chửi nhau bằng
anh bằng kiểu mã hóa
anh nói thế khỏi mày Ông lại chuẩn bị
lên tường nhà tôi mới Star cái cái từ mã
hóa đâu nhé
tôi không dịch rồi à
anh nói chung là điền đầy đủ thông tin
bây giờ chắc là chạy được thôi ông ạ
điền đầy đủ như này sẽ được rồi
à à môi đang để nó bớt từng nghe này nếu
nó sắp ít thì sẽ chạy được quen
nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi chỉ đổi nó này sắp
ít khi mà nói chung á kiểu ra Speed cao
ông chứ dàn ổn rồi đúng không ạ
Ừ không thì nó sẽ hiển thị lỗi ra câu
không không biết
ở
đó thì sẽ đưa xem ít à Đúng rồi còn cái
trường hợp xử lý các chuẩn đấy tự nhiên
tôi đề cập ở đây làm gì bởi vì nếu mà
nếu mà giả sử hồi trước đã từng chơi trò
này và thử cái À bởi vì thằng server nó
không vai biết nữa Thành A tôi lách được
qua nhưng mà tôi không khuyên với ông
nên cho đấy nó cũng được tính là hack
theo cậu là chích cho cậu mẹo bởi vì à
có mấy Nếu không biết bản chất là khi mà
chọn select options này nó nó lấy giá
trị từ trong cái ô trên mình chọn không
ạ Thế bây giờ sửa máy dùng nhát bằng
cách là
bằng cách à Giả sử cái này nó sẽ có cái
khái niệm value cho từng ngày từng ngày
Ocean này nếu không Zalo nó sẽ lấy đúng
cái từ này luôn này
Anh thường cái lập trình này nó sẽ value
là sự bảo lưu à lớp 1 chàng ạ và cái này
sẽ lưu ở lớp 2 được ạ kiểu ngay
đấy thì khi bấm đăng ký này cái bản chất
là nó sẽ gửi cái cái vô lu này lên chứ
không phải là cái chữ mày Thị Loan ngay
đâu thế bây giờ giả sử ở Tôi có trò rồi
đấy rồi có cho tôi lách kiểu Nga phải
sửa sư cái Selection lại sữa nó thành
lớp 3 được ạ Như này
lại như này rồi tôi tôi ở đăng ký ở đấy
giờ đăng ký một phát được luôn không ạ
Không không nghĩa chứng Do nó không
virus bằng ra Switch cũng nhờ Không ai
đẹp bằng
bác em luôn nghĩa Nói chung là cứ điên
lên
em cứ điện này là được thì ra là tôi
đăng ký cái gì đấy Không không phải đăng
ký lớp học đâu anh gửi cái gì đó tự nhớ
nữa Nhưng nói chung à đây mà em bé ông
nghề sửa ảnh ngay Anh cách ra Swift để
kiểm tra nó thì có thể là à
ai có thể chỉ đơn giản là mình mình sẽ
kiểm tra trong có trong danh sách hợp lệ
hay không đúng không ạ Đấy có thể dùng
ra kiểm tra kiểu như thế hoặc bác em thì
kiểm tra do sóc kiểu gì tôi bảo rồi bác
em phải kiểm tra lại một lần nữa ngoại
bởi ra Swift thì thực ra nó vẫn bắt được
cách lát ở đây đó là đơn giản là như nào
với sẽ cho
tôi ghi lại phẳng vẽ hàm kiểm tra này
tôi tôi Đọc cốt ở đây đúng ạ với ẩn
inspect này họ Tôi ăn cơm rồi Tôi xem
tôi xem cốt được mà đúng không ạ à Chỗ
này mày đi tên hành kiểm tra đây rồi
Kiểm tra phone Có những thứ ta sẽ cho nó
luôn hình chu được ngã thì sẽ mình sẽ
ghi đè lên kiểu như này
vì tên Chu tượng đã hứa sẽ luôn Chạy gì
đó
Em bấm vào nó sẽ luôn chạy đúng ạ Đấy
thì thì có nhiều cách để mở reg thì nó
sẽ dùng màn Swift về sẽ như thế
khi tôi vừa rồi tôi nói qua các bạn về
về Dash for bằng ra Switch mặc cũng
những vài chưa trò nó như thế nào Vân
Vân Vân đúng không ạ Các Bạn
ý kiến thức hôm nay rất là nhiều đối với
bạn là không biết gì về asp các từ thứ
lần đầu học cảm thấy vỡ mồm đúng không ạ
nhưng mà Đấy do có video này các bạn xem
lại bà ngoại Còn bây giờ thì
em tranh thủ chia sẻ thêm một vài cái
nhỉ
đi học nhiều không chia sẻ buồn
xe tải thì tôi như tôi đã nói thì tôi sẽ
chia sẻ không được Đây là cái
Vì vậy tôi có nghe bài này nó mặc định
đang lấy cái bài gần nhất thu pháp tôi
ta đã trang nữa sẽ nó nó nói chung là nó
không hẳn lạ nhìn trông vẽ hiệu ứng thế
thôi được nó dị ứng chung có vẻ Đang
nghe rồi thứ kiểu nó đang lấy bài cô ấy
tôi đã phát
và phải tao lạy cha nó mới cập nhật bài
Cô ấy kể kế đoạn đoạn này mình tự ghi
đúng không đầu tiên thì cái trang lít H
là cải trang để chia sẻ Cốt và người
khác nhìn vào đánh giá ông rồng nhưng
cái CV Thế nên thành ra là
tôi muốn chia sẻ mấy ông này mấy ông sửa
lại cái Trang Hý khắp mấy ông CHUNG TỬ
TẾ một tí bởi vì đã còn nhiều nhà tuyển
dụng tìm tôi qua kệ trang trí hát này
A Man City những kiểu là nó gọi cho pp
em ạ
ở nhà giá trị với ông cách để mà các nhà
Tuyển dụng có thể tìm này
Anh nhớ là
đi học bao giờ đi à
Ừ anh vào đây phạm shop này đây
anh không cần tìm ra đâu không tìm theo
kiểu Ngôn ngữ đây p này sao thậm chí là
thường pp được kết hợp với việc là à
em ở Hà Nội chẳng hạn thế
Em nhớ là có cái gõ ở Hà Nội đâu Tôi nhớ
có ở đây
ở đây Hà Nội
anh ạ
chú chó
Cho tôi nghe Tôi tìm tôi nó sẽ ra lên
đầu rồi đúng không ạ nhưng mà còn rất
nhiều nữa này có một loạt nè khi tái soi
hễ inbox cố tìm cách để liên hệ những
cái người này để mà để mà kiểu
đi tìm kiếm thôi không ạ
anh ấy thành ra là kiểu
mấy ông phải chỉnh sửa lại cái trang
get hát của mấy ông đi của bạn
thì cách để mà đầu tiên để mở ra được
cái như thế này thì đầu tiên mấy ông
phải tặng cái Xipo xe Xipo có đúng tên
theo đồng username của ông ấy Nó xảy ra
được cái đoạn cái Trang đấy ông béo và
sửa cái trang Britney
ở đây tôi sẽ cho bé uống xem trang web
mi của tôi
bí
ẩn Alo này xem
ở đây nó sẽ ra như thế này cách để mà
lấy cái đoạn như này thì
Ừ thì hồi đấy à tôi à
em tra Google thôi
chai
spotify It had
playing ạ
Cái nó sẽ
chị sẽ xảy ra có ông Ai hướng dẫn cách
để mà
chị sẽ phải lên trang spotify để mà dán
cắn quyền rồi các thứ thứ như nào nó
cũng đọc nhé Em chịu khó đọc báo bằng
tiếng anh một tí nhưng mà thực ra dễ
thôi đấy thì nó sẽ ra Nói chung là đại
khái được cái kiểu
khi động thổ như kia OK trang của tôi
chị sẽ ra được cái này a tiếp theo mày
cái ảnh này Thực ra là ảnh này tôi lấy à
từ chính cái cái này
chị
sẽ ra một loa tất cả đây mấy ông thể
internet để tìm nó nhanh ra cái ngôn ngữ
hay là thư viện bé uống năng dung sau đó
thì bé ông chè và tôi thích kể tôi đang
dùng cái nền đen là cái thư viện này nó
hỗ trợ cả màu đen với ô trong cũng được
mà không ạ à tiếp ở đó nữa là cái này nó
cập nhật blog tự động A và cái này cập
nhật tự động luôn cả cái vụ YouTube
video của tôi cái làm để làm được cái
đấy thì qua chính cái video này tí thôi
sẽ để link cái video này sẽ hướng dẫn
mấy ông cách để mà vừa mới không biết
qua việc là có một con server miễn phí
của cụ thằng nào ấy ông ông rung con
server đấy thì em à lấy liên tục thì bà
đang từ blog của ông hoặc cả từ kênh
YouTube của ông thậm chí là kiểu tạo à
và sẽ tạo tự đánh giá qua trên trang ký
hát của ông này mà đánh giá kiểu trông
nói như thế này cái ảnh ấy
xe tải
à còn thêm cái đoạn nữa Ở đây mấy ông
đang thấy là tôi cốt bao nhiêu tiếng này
sử dụng cái gì nhiều này thì cái này là
nó lại dùng cái á
cho tôi không Trước tôi đề cập các ông ở
qua Qatar này nó sẽ đánh giá đánh giá
ông
Ồ thông qua ở Việt à nó kiểm tra xem là
ông một tuần không có bao nhiêu tiếng nó
sẽ tự nó sẽ tạo ra một cái ảnh kiểu cựu
thế Nó không đúng ở đây thôi
Ừ thôi không nhớ cái đoạn này làm nhau
nữa sẽ bạn cốt sao mà
Ừ bye bye kiểu step season cuaca máu mái
ông cha cái đoạn này cho ra đấy qua cả
start thứ thứ
chợ
hoa cà tham.tap iPad có mà
khi đó sẽ ra được Kiểu trong ngày về
chưa
Ở đó có gì nói cho mấy ông thấy tôi có
gì tôi chia sẻ được mấy hết rồi
ở tạm như thế nhỉ Hôm nay chồng cũng
giỏi đấy
nghe nhạc không lại bị quá kiến thức
không ạ Tôi sẽ gửi lại trong mấy ông các
thử sao
Ê mày ông còn thắc mắc gì không ạ
Ừ khi nào chia sẻ buổi Đúng rồi còn chữa
bài tập đúng không vẫn quen buổi trưa
thật đấy
Ừ thôi để bữa sau nha Để bữa sau đi vì
sau mấy ông cố nhắc lại tôi nhé à à
cho bộ hôm nay ra khóa quá nhiều
quá nhiều kiến thức rồi quá tải đấy nó
nghỉ ngơi
bộ quà tặng Chào mấy ông em
Ừ có gì thì bình luận Nếu mà Mấy ông
thắc mắc gì buổi sao tôi giải đáp hết
không ạ
khi sex